enfin petite image plus claire sont ces
rires visa c'est ça je vous le dis
girard il paraît que plus jeune arthur
n'avait plus le droit d'emprunter votre
voiture parce que c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois que je prêtais pas lui arriver à
pépins et ça il paraît qu'il a massacré
plein de voitures annoncé pas de sa
faute non s'était jamais de ma faute
ah oui j'avais ma place ah ouais quoi
chaque fois les mecs vous rentrez dedans
j'ai emprunté mais je crois que la
mission de la faire un spectacle à lyon
je me suis fait emboutir après j'ai
emprunté bon à la montagne j'ai crevé
les pneus y avait pas de cri que je ne
l'appelais 80 matin puis viennent le
chercher après je vais emprunter une
voiture et une batterie mais j'avais
fait 200 morts il ya toujours un
problème et donc au final on a misé
dessus j'ai dit j'étais jeune j'étais
monsieur pas me prêter une voiture feu
non mais j'ai tant loué une violence et
du scooter et il se viande à wayne info
passage ou pas giraille paraît qu'arthur
est partie en colonie de vacances et que
le directeur était le sosie de vous
parce que c'est vrai style soit
québécois
oui oui je suis qu on se voit très peu
oui c'était peut-être vous en faites
peut-être c'était qu'il fallait pas avec
les choristes
or il paraît qu'à côte de vote 6 vous
avez dû jouer dans une pièce de théâtre
sans aucune répétition
ah oui c'est vrai c'est quoi cette
histoire ça c'est un très beau souvenir
qu'on a eus ensemble ils m'appellent il
joua une pièce avec avignon avignon et
moi je jouais avignon et en étant tourné
avec une pièce de feydeau en même temps
et je devais moi le soir jouer à 21h30 à
fréjus en plein air ou un gros événement
avec 1500 personnes et le producteur
m'appelle à 14h en dix ans
rinaldi qui jouait le rôle principal a
eu un pépin faut qu'ils fassent face à
un pacemaker et c est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un avignon tu peut embarquer qui
va lire le texte en main puis une façon
peut pas annuler ses dents quatre heures
les gens leur billet et lui l'appelle
toi tu l'as vu deux fois la pièce à
feydeau est ce que tu veux faire la
lecture 8 es foutu et bien mort est
divisé
j'avais à dîner bon je raccroche puis
bon j'ai bien entendu à sa voix que ce
n'était pas bien je perdais beaucoup de
poids j'ai rappelé jibé coup de pioche
rallye cultivait les pieds en fait ça a
été une seule un souvenir c'était parce
qu'il était en vacances dans le sud
il a pris sa voiture il est parti ils
ont fait une espèce de lecture de la
pièce avec la troupe moi j'étais avignon
donc je n'ai pas fait cette lecture je
suis arrivé à 21h32 ainsi elle j'ai vu
mon père dans le costume noir rinaldi et
puis on est monté sur scène et le puits
qui était pas au courant il est mon nom
j'ai fait une petite annonce valable
rinaldi lui en suis certain que c'est il
jouera pas dans toute la salle féraud et
v10 bomba donc on a cherché un comédien
qu'il faut élire le rôle qui est un peu
en galère qui voulait un papy cachetons
et voilà j'étais une fille est donc et
c'était comme des fonds est géré c'est
que le seul acteur qui avait accepté de
relever le défi c'était un monsieur qui
s'appelait gérard jugnot d'un coup il ya
eu le haut et avoir eu 1500 appareil
photo mais elle un minute le temps
d'être très romancé mais les choses dans
la pièce qui correspondait il parraine
mon père femme son père je vais en ville
d'ibb l'équipe rocco et puis il
connaissait aucun déplacement qui il
parti
[Applaudissements]